[Musique]
salut à toutes et à tous bonjour et
bienvenue dans sénat stream votre
émission hebdomadaire avec public sénat
on a le plaisir de recevoir un sénateur
une sénatrice qui vient répondre à vos
questions chaque semaine cette semaine
on a le plaisir de recevoir valérie
boyer bonjour bonjour comment allez vous
ça va très bien je viens d'installer
vient d'arriver
on dit bien la salle el-assad est
profondément tant mieux et bah c'est
parfait on va passer une heure ensemble
valérie boyer on va apprendre à vous
connaître je rappelle que vous êtes
sénatrice les républicains des bouches
du rhône
bonjour à vous si vous nous regardez
actuellement sur twitter bonjour à vous
également si vous ne regardez sur public
sénat le canal 13 de la tnt c'est vous
qui avaient préparé des questions pour
valérie boyer c'est moi qui vais les
poser
on va parler de vous valez voyez on va
apprendre à vous connaître mais avant ça
on va commencer par parler d'un moment
un sujet d'actualité c'est parti pour le
moment actu alors évidemment l'actualité
la plus chaude c'est la nouvelle vague
de restrictions qui ont commencé à
entrer en vigueur dès le week end
dernier notamment la fermeture des
écoles le reprise de l'école à la maison
pour beaucoup d'enfants avec des
difficultés non négligeable j'ai une
première question pour vous qui est
posée par jacques a dit ça s'invente pas
fallait-il fermer les écoles plus tôt je
pense qu'il ya pas de bonne réponse à
cette question à la france a choisi de
laisser les écoles ouverte le plus
longtemps possible
c'est vrai que ça a été un choix
français mais compte tenu de l'évolution
de
l'épidémie de la pandémie on a décidé de
fermer les écoles avec la polémique est
ce que les enfants transmettent le virus
ou pas bon voilà est-ce qu'il faut les
vacciner ou pas mais surtout ce qui est
surprenant c'est qu'on s'attendait au
bout d'un an à ce qu'il n'y ait pas de
bug pour l'école à la maison
via des médias modernes et alors que le
ministre avait dit on est prêts on est
prêt et que franchement ça a mal démarré
à tel point que le président de la
république a dû faire diversion en
faisant semblant de se connecter et de
par les échos l'école avec des
collégiens 6 à jean-michel longueur
expliqué que c'étaient les régions qui
étaient responsables
comme on dit quand c'est pas moi c'est
l'autre maîtresse c'est pas moi c'est
franchement sa réponse était à la fois
fébrile et nerveuse et pas à la hauteur
des enjeux les interrogations parce que
faire l'école à la maison ça veut dire
qu'il ya des parents qui se sentent
aidés travail aussi c'est déjà très
compliquée si en plus on sait pas
organiser pour alors que ça fait plus
d'un an qu'on du travail je trouve ça
quand même un peu triste d'ailleurs je
trouve que c'est significatif de ces
actions je vais vous poser c'est à dire
quelque chose pour vous du gouvernement
des jeunes mais aussi peut-être ça dit
quelque chose de ce que les français
ressentent à la fois je dirais entre
colère et une certaine forme de
désespoir du déclassement français je
pense que notre cette crise due
du coronavirus nous a fait prendre
conscience de beaucoup de choses la
première c'est qu'on pensait avoir le
meilleur système de santé du monde on
s'aperçoit que non la deuxième c'est
qu'on croyait que l'exception culturelle
française avec l'éducation avec la
culture était quelque chose de très très
fort et qu'on pourrait que ça nous
mettait un petit peu à part des autres
pays
or au lieu de s'appuyer sur la culture
on a fermé les lieux culturels et avec
pour moi quelque chose d'absolument
incroyable comment dire aux gens que
dans les musées dans les monuments même
dans certaines salles de spectacles et
dans des salles de cinéma on va se
contaminer alors qu'on va dans le métro
si ça se compare à comprendre
oui je dirais même le choix d'aller dans
le métro doit les ou d'accord mais
pourquoi arrêter la vie quand on sait
que ce sont des lieux où on ne se
contaminent pas pourquoi ne pas faire en
sorte que la vie reprenne
alors que ça reprend en espagne que ça
reprend dans d'autres pays alors
pourquoi ne pas tester
pourquoi c'est ça c'est ça que je ne
comprends pas moi je comprends qu'on
arrête les choses quand il est prouvé
que ces choses-là transmettent cette
maladie en revanche quand il est prouvé
par ailleurs et qu'on fait des tests que
ça ne transmet pas la maladie je ne
comprends pas qu'on arrête la vie dès
lors qu'il ne désirant pas qu'on arrête
la vie par exemple dans les universités
alors qu'on sait combien les étudiants
souffrent aujourd'hui dès lors qu il dès
lors que la décision est prise de fermer
les écoles une question de carrasso qui
vous demande ne faut-il pas prendre un
peu plus de temps pour que les
enseignants puissent se préparer les
enseignants apprennent le jeudi comme
nous tous à la télévision que lundi ce
ça c'est une c'est une chose qui m'a
beaucoup étonné parce que je pensais que
depuis un an les enseignants et
l'éducation nationale se préparait
à l'école à la maison de cette façon on
s'est aperçu que non c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose c'est que je
peins je ne comprends pas que la période
de confinement parce que c'est une
période de confinement en tout cas de
confinement scolaire ne soit pas utilisé
pour organiser la vaccination
prioritairement des enseignants et ça
s'est pas fait pourquoi dire que c'est à
dire qu'il ya pas une campagne de
vaccination qui viserait prioritairement
des enseignants pour qu'ils aient des
dodos cependant le mois d'arrêt parce
que vous savez qu'il faut à peu près 15
jours pour après les doses pour qu'on
soit totalement sûr d'être bien
immunisés donc c'est ça qui m'étonne
c'est que on ne profite pas le problème
c'est pas la difficulté tout le monde
est dans la difficulté avec cette
pandémie
ce qui me surprend c'est le manque
d'organisation par rapport aux
sacrifices qu'on demande aux français
parce qu'aujourd'hui effectivement tout
semble tout va très bien madame la
marquise
on dit que la france c'est la france qui
a le plus aidé ces entreprises et
l'économie à fonctionner mais c'est de
l'argent magique et on sait bien que
l'argent magique c'est de tout genre
maléfique très vite puisque avant la
dette je crois qu'on était à 34 milles
euros de dettes par français et
qu'aujourd'hui on est autour des 36 38
peut-être 40000 euros par français donc
ça veut dire que cet argent un jour il
faudra bien le rendre et on ne l'aura
plus pour le réinjecter dans l'économie
une fois que la crise sera sera parti
donc ce sera derrière nous ce qui me
surprend c'est que pour l'enseignement
voilà un exemple concret récents on dise
ok on ferme les écoles mais la priorité
c'est de faire vacciner les enseignants
parce que c'est eux qui demain vont être
en première ligne pour reprendre l'école
vous avez parlé de la vaccination
valérie boyer vous êtes éligible pour le
vaccin astrazeneca louis vous êtes
éligible
est ce que vous êtes vacciné aujourd'hui
encore est déjà eu il me faut qu'une
seule dose
vous avez déjà eu le virus oui et donc
du coup il nous faut qu'une seule dose
effectivement quand on a déjà été
contaminées par l'aco vite 19
une seule dose suffit donc j'attends de
voir quand je serai disent pas l'origine
des questions on m'a demandé est ce
qu'en tant que sénatrice vous allez
bénéficier d'un centre de vaccination au
sénat où est ce que vous allez faire la
queue ou vaccinodromes comme toutes les
deux sont possibles parce que vous savez
qu'il ya plein d'entreprises qui peuvent
vacciner ya pas de vaccinodromes au
sénat mais à marseille il ya un
vaccinodromes qui a été mis en place
grâce aux marins pompiers de marseille
que je salue et que je remercie vous
savez que ce sont les marins pompiers de
marseille qui ont inventé la technique
pour surveiller l'évolution de la
maladie dans des eaux usées et ce sont
eux qui ont créé le premier
vaccinodromes français d'ailleurs ce
serait bien que cette technique qui nous
a été envoyé par les pays étrangers
puissent aujourd'hui se développer
dans toute la france c'est
malheureusement pas le cas d'accord une
question d'elisabeth qui vous demande si
vous êtes favorable au maintien des
élections en juin
est ce que c'est vraiment raisonnable il
n'y a pas un problème d'être favorable
ou pas favorable quelles sont les
conditions pour que ces élections se
tiennent correctement
moi je ne suis pas pour confiner la
démocratie mais il ya deux choses pour
les élections est ce que il est possible
de faire campagne correctement organisé
ces élections ne sait toujours pas s que
les assesseurs les teneurs de bureaux
devront être vaccinés au fait qu'est ce
qui va se passer
moi je ne voudrais pas que qu'il y ait
le même fiasco que pour les élections
municipales ou où la veille deux le
samedi soir on a appris qu'on allait
être confinés lundi ce qui a quand même
créé un mouvement de panique terrible et
qui a modifié le score est dans ce sens
que oui ça n'a pas rassuré un certain
nombre de personnes il ya toute une
partie de personnes qui ne sont pas
venus ensuite après on a accusé les élus
d'avoir transmis le virus les bureaux
d'avoir été des lieux de contamination
donc tout ça crée un climat extrêmement
malsain pour la démocratie
donc aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on va
faire
qui est il possible de faire toute façon
le sénat a voté un certain nombre de
choses donc il faudra bien se décider
j'ai reçu beaucoup de questions vous
vous en doutez sur la polémique qui
monte autour de l'organisation de dîners
de dîners mondains je vois ça vous fait
sourire c'est triste quand même là qui
mena mais qu'est ce qui est triste c'est
ce que est ce qu est ce que vous êtes ce
que vous condamnez l'organisation de ces
dîners au mépris des règles sanitaires
moi je pense que
c'est pas un problème de mondanités
c'est un problème de personnes qui
enfreignent les règles
je condamne ce genre de choses de la
même façon que j'ai condamné le carnaval
de la honte qui a eu lieu à marseille
d'accord palau à la fois au mépris des
règles sanitaires et en plus pour casser
parce que des filets au carnaval pour
dire tout le monde déteste la police est
cassé du mobilier urbain et uriné sur
des lieux de mémoire
ça me semble pas être quelque chose de
très positif surtout que on a appris
qu'un certain nombre d'élus avaient
participé du printemps marseillais
auraient participé à cette manifestation
ça me semble totalement incroyable alors
je ne sais pas si cette polémique est
vraie ou fausse
mais aujourd'hui c'est ça qui est pas
normal c'est que il y a des règles et on
les respecte même si ça nous coûte de
plus voir les gens ça nous coûte de plus
aller au restaurant ça nous coûte de
plus aller au barça nous coûte de voir
les magasins fermés ça nous coûte de
plus voir nos parents quand on le
souhaiterait tout ça effectivement nous
coûte
mais ces règles là qu'on estime qu'elle
soit valable ou pas ça fait partie des
règles de vie en société et on les
enfreint pas moi je pense que c'est pas
un problème de mondanités c'est un
problème de comportement civique est ce
que vous pensez qu'il ya du deux poids
deux mesures de deux poids deux mesures
pardon dans le contrôle effectué par la
police par exemple sur sûr c'est sûr
c'est sur ces infractions on pense au
barbecue organisé en banlieue ou voilà
où la police débarque assez facilement
et on entend parler de dîners mondains
dans des beaux quartiers
j'espère que non je peux pas y croire
parce que moi j'ai confiance dans la
police de mon pays et que je sais qu'il
ya des fêtes privées qui ont été
interdites où des gens ont été
sanctionnés c'est à peu près du même
niveau que c'est fait là alors
maintenant à savoir si des ministres ou
pas ont participé écoutez j'espère
franchement qui a aucun ministre assez
stupide pour s'y rendre enfin vraiment
parce que sinon ça c'est qu'elle
démissionnait ça c'est le problème des
manuels macro et de son gouvernement
mais franchement quelle crédibilité
c'est jeu
franchement je suis dans l'opposition
mais je veux pas croire à ce genre de
chose enfin hockey une enquête est
ouverte
non j'espère que non très bien on va
faire seul et triste pour l'engagement
public est encore une fois pour la vie
politique dans son ensemble on va
apprendre à vous connaître un peu mieux
valérie boyer c'est parti pour le moment
portrait
valérie boyer vous avez fait sciences po
à aix vous vouliez faire quoi plus tard
aulas avant avant ça j'avais fait des
lettres classiques
je voulais faire quoi jeu
j'avais envie de travailler dans la
diplomatie j'imagine est absolument pas
travailler va être sauna triste ça
faisait pas partie du plan n'ont ni même
de faire de la politique même si je me
suis toujours en fin même si j'ai
toujours eu conscience de l'importance
de la politique dans la vie alors
c'était ma question suivante c'est
arrivé comment la politique dans votre
vie est ce que en famille c'était un
étaient présents bien sûr moi je fais
partie d'une famille pour laquelle on
sait que la politique ça de l'importance
dans la vie des gens ça peut changer
votre vie puisque mes parents sont nés
en france dans des départements français
mais d'algérie mon père est né à
mostaganem maman est né dans un
protectorat français qui était la
tunisie
donc ils ont été rapatriés en 62 dans
des conditions extrêmement difficiles
donc je sais que la politique a de
l'importance dans la vie des gens je
sais aussi qu'elle peut changer la vie
des gens parce que j'ai un grand père
maltais qui a été adoptée par la france
comme ça se faisait à l'époque dans les
protectorats donc ce sont des exemples
personnels qui font que j'ai toujours eu
conscience que c'était quelque chose
d'important et je me suis toujours
intéressé c'est vrai que quand j'étais
en sixième jeu suivez avec attention
avec patients le journal télévisé dont
j'ai écouté les conversations des
adultes je m'y intéresser engagement je
vais sûrement beaucoup proposé aussi à
mes professeurs
oui puisque j'avais des professeurs
communiste qui nous faisaient de la
propagande et c'est alors il y avait ça
il y avait le fait que mon papa travail
est aussi ce qui était assez rare à
l'époque derrière le rideau de fer
c'est à dire qu'il allait souvent pour
son activité professionnelle derrière le
rideau de fer
je savais ce que c'était de vivre en
prison entre mon histoire personnelle
est ce que j'entendais de l'activité
dans mon papa je le savais d'accord ok
d'anticommunisme qui est né de ça je
suppose ça expliquerait votre engagement
à droite en partie oui puis pas
simplement pour ça pourquoi
mais aussi parce que je sais
la dureté du monde communiste
ça c'est quelque chose et comme moi j'ai
vécu dans la banlieue parisienne
moi j'avais des profs qui distribuait
des journaux communistes à la sortie de
l'école même un curé communiste qu'il
faut les faire redoubler ma communion
donc tout ça qu'être communion donc tout
ça c'est effectivement ça ça vous forge
aussi une conscience politique et c'est
probablement pour ça que ça m'a toujours
intéressé j'ai pas fais lieu paix par
hasard parce que j'ai fait des lettres
classiques j'étais plutôt destiné à
faire une école artistique pour ça
qu'après j'ai fait la petite école du
louvre
mais en fait j'ai hésité entre ça et
quelque chose plutôt dans le monde des
arts de l'histoire de l'art et de la
restauration est en fait celle c'est
l'engagement public qui m'a guidé après
dans ma vie professionnelle d'accord
une question d'une question de choco qui
vous demande quelle est la diversité des
idées au sein des républicains est ce
qui a toujours une hétérogénéité des
courants au sein des républicains ou
est-ce que ça s'est rétrécie à peau de
chagrin aujourd'hui et bien sûr toute
façon c'est l'adn de notre famille
politique on est tout sauf monolithique
c'est comme ça bien sûr toujours c'est
toujours la droite et le centre c'est
l'union pour un ben oui l'union pour un
mouvement populaire et républicain
ça représente
on a différents courants bien évidemment
emmanuel macron n'a pas attiré à lui
tout un courant de la droite centriste
européenne libérale
je pense que c'est une vie de l'esprit
de penser qu'un manuel macro et de
droite c'est peut-être qu'il aimerait
qu'il aimerait faire croire des deux
roues je pense ni l'un ni l'autre je
pense qu'ils les maquereaux n'y en ait
que son mouvement s'arrêtera avec lui
puisque ça repose sur sa personne
je sais que
50% des députés puisque son mouvement ne
repose que sur des députés tout le reste
je rappelle quand même que manuel macron
et le modem ont fait 3 % aux élections
municipales
ils ont très peu de communes
effectivement les différences de comics
1 ils ont 3 % en tout de tout de tous
les votes donc le moment de 2,7
élections de 2017
c'était un moment très spécial dans la
vie démocratique française puisqu'on a
quand même volé la campagne
présidentielle aux français il n'y a pas
une débats sur les projets il ya eu le
procès de fillon qui a remplacé le débat
sur les élections présidentielles
emmanuel macron a été lu par un concours
de circonstances
pas sur des idées pas sur un mouvement
parce qu'il était là et que on aurait
mis n'importe quel candidat je pense
devant marine le pen il aurait été élu
derrière ça sur le cas en 2011 dont il
s'agit on verra bien mais en tout cas
une chose est sûre c'est qu'il a raté
son pari d'être le rempart à marine le
pen parce qu'elle s'est jamais aussi
bien portée mais pour en revenir à
l'élection des législatives de 2010 est
je rappelle que 47% un petit peu plus de
47% des députés qui ont été élues à
l'assemblée nationale avait une
étiquette parti socialiste cinq minutes
avant de se découvrir des tic est en
marche
47 % étaient engagés directement au
parti socialiste
donc après le droit extrêmement sait
même pas 10% bruno le maire gérald or
s'ils disent que sans risque de guerre
ce sont des prises de guerre de
personnes qui pour un poste ont trahi
leurs idées et leur famille politique
ce qu'ils ont vraiment trahi ce que la
politique menée par emmanuel macron
depuis 2010 est n'est pas ne correspond
pas finalement au programme de l'ump des
républicains ah non on en quoi par
exemple citer mans un exemple bien sûr
l'autorité par exemple la pression des
manifestations la lutte contre le contre
le séparatisme alors je ne confonds pas
autorité et autoritarisme d'accord déjà
donc je pense que je ne vois pas trop il
autorités je vois plutôt l'autoritarisme
parce que les chiffres de la délinquance
sont extrêmement mauvais et quant à la
lutte sur le séparatisme le texte que
nous sommes en train d'examiner au sénat
aujourd'hui
bien heureusement que les sénateurs
les républicains étaient là pour faire
voter vraiment des choses qui vont
changer et apporter quelque chose à la
lutte contre le séparatisme raciste un
texte qui ne dit pas son nom mais j'ai
vu j'ai plein de questions pour vous
tout à l'heure sur ce texte là je
voulais pas qu'on y vienne tout de suite
je continue sur messieurs choses sur ces
discussions qui à mon avis sont
intéressantes sur l'identité de droite
quel est l'espace politique qui reste
aux républicains entre eux entre le
ration nation d'un côté et la république
en marge de l'autre moi je dirais que
notre espace politique est immense parce
que parce que emmanuel macron pour moi
c'est l'ère du vide
il n'existe que parce que nous sommes
aujourd'hui pas capables de nous trouver
à leader pas capables de nous trouver un
quelqu'un qui incarne ce que les
françoises ce que les français
souhaitent majoritairement c'est à dire
une politique qui fasse autorité sur la
sécurité
une politique qui protège sur le plan
social et cette difficulté que nous
avons à avoir un chef un carnet avant un
leader à nous trouver un leader fait que
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron est là parce
que nous n'avons pas de candidat qui
dépassent pour l'instant pour l'instant
la barre du deuxième tour effet s'ils
ont effectivement effectivement qu'est
ce qu'il y à il ya mélenchon le pen ou
emmanuel macron donc pour laisser torres
suis convaincu et en tout cas je plaide
pour ça qu'à l'intérieur de notre
famille politique nous avons des talents
susceptibles justement de ramener les
français un vrai programme est un vrai
projet à même de nous sortir des
difficultés dans lesquelles nous nous
trouvons aujourd'hui êtes-vous favorable
à une primaire pour le respect du
littoral à un départage parce que de
toute façon sans se partagent sans cette
primaire sans se départagent nous ne
pourrons pas dégager une personnalité
alors qu'est ce que vous pensez de
l'initiative de xavier bertrand qui sont
bleu expliqué qu'ils sont à franchir en
mai il a quitté les républicains ils
risquent pas d'être le candidat légitime
tout de même du mouvement
écoutez nous verrons bien mais la
moindre des choses
que nous devons faire aujourd'hui c'est
trouver un candidat avec nos couleurs
moi je ne peux pas croire que avec les
succès que nous avons enregistrés aux
élections municipales dans les
départements que nous détenons en
majorité les régions que nous détenons
en majorité le parti le grand parti de
gouvernement qui est quand même les
républicains nous ne puissions pas
incarner l'alternance par rapport quand
même aux échecs du maquereau nisme une
question de panneaux qui vous demande en
cas de victoire de marine le pen en 2022
et ce qu'elle pourra compter sur le
soutien de membres des républicains dans
le cas d'une maison dans la ville
antique fiction je ne crois pas du tout
à la victoire de marine le pen en 2022
pas du tout à ce stade vous ne me croyez
pas sa présence au second tour elle est
probable on verra bien de toute façon
les scénarios écrits d'avancé ne
fonctionne jamais qui aurait pu imaginer
qu'on retrouverait emmanuel macron face
à marine le pen pour une fois qu'ils
étaient là on connaissait le résultat
maintenant
on sait très bien que les choses
auxquelles on pense à un moment donné en
tout cas il ya toujours une règle les
favoris et les personnes qu'on imaginait
au deuxième tour des élections des
élections présidentielles c'était
rarement les mêmes un an avant et un an
après je vois quelqu'un dans le chat qui
dit edouard philippe en solutions pour
les républicains
vous avez parlé de trahison tout à
l'heure ça me paraît non j'y crois pas
trop non plus mais ça mais ça
n'intéresse le retour de douar philippe
qui écrit un livre écoutez vous voyez
bien quand même la nécessité avec les
deux questions qu'on m'avait posé sur
emmanuel macron à edouard philippe pour
nous de trouver un candidat
je comprends bien c'est pour ça que je
suis une
c'est une c'est une solution c'est
quelque chose qui est impératif
donc si edouard philippe reprendre
l'étiquette la république et enverra une
question de funky qui vous demandent
qu'est-ce qui distingue finalement les
républicains du rassemblement national
les questions très directes
oui enfin je suis un petit peu fatigué
de répondre à ce genre de questions
qu'on voulait c'est parce que on nous la
peau sous le temps on pourrait poser
qu'est ce qui est enfin je trouve que
c'est une vision très caricatural de
devoir de voir les choses
j'ai pas de mépris pour les électeurs
quel qu'il soit d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
ce qui nous distingue c'est que nous
sommes un parti responsable de
gouvernement qu'on a envie vraiment de
faire avancer qu'on est aussi un parti
de rassemblement aux différents courants
peuvent s'exprimer et que nous avons des
solutions je le crois profondément en
tout cas nous y travaillons aux maux qui
mais qui aime ax bien sûr qui font
souffrir les français aujourd'hui
puisque marine le pen a réussi sa
stratégie de dédiabolisation un récent
sondage montrait que beaucoup de jeunes
étaient prêts à voter pour elle en 2022
elle aussi elle bénéficie de ce vide est
aussi due de ce duo le pen macron sur
lequel emmanuel moi j'ai toujours dit
que marine le pen c'est l'assurance vie
d'emmanuel macro et inversement
je veux dire là ne pourra pas exister
sans l'autre d'accord vous avez été élue
sénatrice en septembre dernier et vous
veniez vous étiez députés à ce moment là
vous êtes passé directement du palais
bourbon au palais du luxembourg
une question de chino qui vous demandent
pourquoi avoir brigué un mandat de
sénateur que vous étiez déjà débuté
alors je oui j'ai été élu trois fois
député dans des circonstances
à chaque fois extrêmement compliqué en
2007 puisque j'ai gagné c'est la
conscription sur la gauche en 2012 alors
que françois hollande venait d'être élu
et en 2017
après alors que nous n'avions plus de
candidats vous avez résisté
effectivement j'avais été élu maire
également bas parce que ça faisait mon
deuxième mandat dans l'opposition à
l'assemblée nationale
et peut-être que vous avez pu voir que
j'étais une parlementaire très active
puisque j'ai déposé des centaines
d'amendements beaucoup de propositions
de loi donc beaucoup d'ailleurs ont pu
enfin un certain nombre ont pu prospérer
dans des domaines extrêmement différent
et je trouvais qu'il y avait un
abaissement terrible du parlement alors
qu'il y ait à des réformes
institutionnelles comme le quinquennat
par exemple et surtout depuis
l'avènement d' emmanuel macron que
c'était extrêmement difficile pour
l'opposition de s'exprimer qui avait
aucun respect de l'opposition chez vous
citer un chiffre quand je suis parti de
l'assemblée nationale nous avons voté à
peu près 40% des textes proposés
et des amendements proposés par les
lamas cronie enfin par emmanuel macron
et ses amis aux gouvernements eux mêmes
n'ont voté que moi de 1%
c'est l'ouverture d'esprit alors quand
on dit que manuel mc ren et de droite
en tout cas ils ne prouvent pas et qui
n'est ni de droite ni de gauche non il
est emmanuel macron points lui je vous
qui votez sésame au népal inverse même
pire des fois il les redonnais écoutez
moi ça m'est arrivé sur un sujet et
après je vais répondre à la question du
sénat qui ça m'est arrivé sur un sujet
qui aurait pu faire consensus pour tout
le monde c'était notamment en cas de
violence conjugale le retrait de
l'autorité parentale du parent violent
et ça a lui-même été les premiers mots
du premier ministre lorsqu'on avait fait
le grenelle des violences conjugales
et moi j'avais des propositions de lois
dans ce domaine depuis longtemps et
notamment sur ce sujet là depuis 2015 et
donc quand edouard philippe s'est
exprimé au grenelle des violences
conjugales en disant il n'est pas
possible qu'un parent violent puisse
continuer à être considéré qu'à mari
violent puisque on puisse continuer
pardon être considéré comme un bon
parent ce qui était une évidence
je me souviens je la vois je lis
monsieur le premier ministre cheikh
edwards ça tombe bien puisque moi dans
une niche les républicains je vais une
niche parlementaire je vais défendre ce
projet de loi et la ministre de la
justice m'a dit clairement un an et
coûtait c'est vous c'est pas possible
donc qu'est ce que j'ai fait alors que
c'est un sujet qui devrait faire
consensus
j'ai comme le texte passer au sénat
j'applique de renault retailleau et je
lui ai dis franchement au président du
groupe luke adam du groupe l'est
républicain au sénat du groupe
majoritaire au sénat
je lui dis franchement ce texte non
seulement j'y tiens sur le plan
personnel parce que ça fait des années
que je travaille sur cette question mais
en plus j'y tiens par rapport à toutes
les familles que j'ai pu recevoir et qui
sont aujourd'hui dans la souffrance par
rapport à ce sujet qu'il devrait faire
consensus
et il l'a fait passer au sénat en
commission mixte paritaire
donc vous voyez par cette anecdote à la
fois les difficultés qu'on peut avoir à
travailler avec des gens qui prétendent
respecter l'opposition alors qu'ils ne
le font pas
mais aussi le respect de l'opposition
qui n'y est pas donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai décidé d'aller au
sénat où j'ai un espace d'expression qui
est qui est plus important est
d'ailleurs le texte sur le séparatisme
le prouve
franchement je salue avec beaucoup
d'affection et d'amitié mes collègues
les républicains de l'assemblée
nationale parce qu'ils font un travail
auquel j'ai participé activement
formidable d'opposition mais quand vous
avez la possibilité de faire valoir vos
idées de façon plus approfondie
eh bien vous la saisissent et ça a été
mon cas et je suis très heureuse et vous
voilà donc élue sénatrice depuis
septembre dernier
c'est parti pour le moment c'est nord
alors hausse était parfaite pour sa part
fait une question de l'omi qui vous
demande simplement est ce que vous
trouvez plus simple d'être saynètes
risque députés c'est la différence entre
les deux est passé d'une chambre à
l'autre
est ce que vous sentez il n'y a pas plus
simple au plus compliqué c'est mon
boulot c'est un travail législatif qui
de toute façon c'est un travail
législatif qui ressemble bien évidemment
à mende
invention proposition de loi et cetera
c'est sûr mais c'est un travail aussi
qui est différent par rapport à son
territoire puisque aujourd'hui c'est
plus simplement la circonscription des
bouches du rhône la première
circonscription des bouches du rhône où
j'étais député j'ai été élu député trois
fois c'est fou j'ai été maire aussi
puisque j'ai été maire de cette
circonscription s'est lentement
c'est le département et c'est un travail
plus approfondi avec les collectivités
locales avec les collectivités
territoriales et avec les maires du
département et les conseillers
municipaux du département donc ça vous
montre ça vous appréciez ce travail de
terrain avec les avec les élus locaux
oui enfin même si aujourd'hui le terrain
est très compliquée du fait de la
pandémie on a des difficultés à se
déplacer on a des difficultés à tenir
des réunions on a des difficultés à se
rencontrer ça c'est sûr oui je
n'apprécie pas ce qu'on a bien vu qu'au
coeur de la crise
vraiment ce qu'ils étaient ce qui était
fondamental pour les français et ce qui
a permis aussi de tenir pendant la crise
eût coronavirus ce sont les
collectivités locales
ce sont elles qui étaient à la manoeuvre
pour les masses ce sont elles qui
étaient à la manoeuvre pour les tests ce
sont elles qui étaient à la manoeuvre
pour pallier malheureusement les grosses
difficultés qu'a pu rencontrer le
gouvernement pendant ce premier
confinement j'ai une question de large
qui vous demander ce que vous pensez
avoir plus d'impact politique au sénat
qu'à l'assemblée
je sais pas à la limite c'est lui qui me
le dira non mais c'est d'un côté nous
allons demander non repris par la
majorité
je peux vous dire que j'ai noté alors je
suis désolé je saisis je vous en prie
j'ai noté regarder tout ce que nous
avons pu faire passer aujourd'hui dans
la loi sur le séparatisme au sénat alors
les pas encore votée définitivement
cette histoire mais si ça saute en cmp
fin mais ce que je veux dire
je pense que le gouvernement ne peut pas
dire d'un côté je veux lutter conte le
centre le séparatisme islamique sans
nommer et ne pas prendre des mesures
que nous avons voté contre son avis
alors je précise que vous êtes une
dessinatrice les plus en avant sur la
question de la loi sion séparatisme en
ce moment au sénat donc allez-y
effectivement le voile sur le voile sur
les mineurs est passé ces interdictions
dur l'interdiction du voile pour les
mineurs que je considère non pas comme
un signe religieux mais comme de la
maltraitance parce qu'on n'a pas
expliqué aux petites filles qu'elles
sont pudiques
si elle porte un voile et impudique si
elle ne le portent pas ça vaut aussi
pour l'équipe a et les croix pour ça n'a
rien à voir
le croit la croix n'est pas un symbole
d'oppression il accroît ne m'explique
pas aux gens que la crosse un sentiment
d'appartenance qui est porté par des
milliers et des millions de français
c'est pas un symbole d'oppression cacher
les cheveux d'une petite fille ça veut
lui c'est pour lui dire que si elle ne
porte pas le voile sur ses cheveux c'est
qu'elle est impudique
c'est ça que ça veut dire donc c'est
exactement l'inversé de ce que l'on
apprend on ce qui est de ses seins
interdit de liberté ça n'interdit de
fraternité ça n'interdit d'égalité c'est
un interdit d'altérité donc notre
message ne veut pas être celui ci pour
les mineurs ça c'est une réalité
le burqini dans les piscines terminé le
fait qu'on considère que l'école dans
les murs et les cols hors les murs les
mêmes règles s'appliquent
c'est à dire des règles de neutralité
c'est à dire l'école louis les
accompagnatrices connaît suffisamment
scolaire c'est l'interdiction du port du
voile
les réunions séparatistes on sait par
les blancs des noirs terminé aussi les
listes communautaires notamment pour
lutter contre l'entrisme du parti
égalité justice de recep tayyip erdogan
qui a présenté des candidats aux
élections législatives de 2010 est moi
j'ai eu des candidats du parti égalité
justice contre moi enfin qui se
présentait dans la circonscription
la première circonscription des bouches
du rhône je l'avais interrogé emmanuel
macron nouvellement élu à cette époque
président de la république pour lui dire
comment se fait-il que nous ayons des
listes qui se revendique directement en
un parti de l'étranger que vous
n'interdisez pas ces listes ben voilà
maintenant les sénateurs ont voté le
fait qu'on interdise ces listes là le
fait que la caf et l'obligation de
déclarer la polygamie ça c'est un
amendement que j'ai pu faire voter
directement le fait aussi que
l'amendement samuel pâtit alors ça mes
collègues ont pu lé 10 1 mais elle pâtit
est libre les collègues ont pu le faire
voter à l'assemblée
c'est le délit d' entrave en plus de
faire voter à l'assemblée nationale
heureusement le drapeau le fait que ce
soit le drapeau français comme le
déclare l'article 1 d'ailleurs de la
constitution qui soit mis et qui pavoise
dans les mairies notamment au moment des
mariages ça s'est passé grâce au sénat
le fait que des étrangers qui ont eu des
actions terroristes ne puissent être
embauché dans certaines conditions
voilà des personnes voilà il ya plein
d'autres choses
la liste que vous venez de faire ce sont
effectivement des amendements que votre
groupe et la majorité sénatoriale a fait
passer dans la loi c'est par contre
celle du gouvernement contre l'avis du
gouvernement et c'est justement où je
veux en venir qu'à l'histoire avez-vous
que ces mesures que vous avez apporté
finissent dans la loi effective à
l'issue de son travail du ce natif
écoutez j'ai j'espère parce qu'on ne
peut pas d'un côté avoir des
déclarations de laïcité de madame
schiappa et d'autorité de monsieur
darmana de justice de monsieur dupont
moretti et d'égalité du ministre
d'éducation nationale si c'était que
cela ne passe pas donc heureusement que
le sénat était là pour donner corps à ce
texte séparatisme sinon de l'avis
général ce texte servait à quoi embêter
toutes les religions sauf celle qui pose
un problème
l'enseignement à domicile que j'ai
oublié l'enseignement famille aussi nous
avons supprimé les difficultés les
entraves que le gouvernement souhaitait
mettre à l'enseignement en famille qui
voulait justement pour le coup lutter
contre le séparatisme
il ya les enfants qui sont les colonnes
la maison non mais qui embêter tout le
monde c'est à dire qu'ils n'arrivaient
pas à lutter contre le séparatisme et
qui embêtait les parents qui ont choisi
l'enseignement en famille nous sommes un
pays où on a le choix de l'enseignement
c'est même une liberté constitutionnelle
puisque nous avons l'enseignement public
l'enseignement privé sous contrat
l'enseignement hors contrat et
l'enseignement en famille on voulait
entraver cette dernière possibilité
c'est pas possible
vous vous doutez bien que j'ai reçu
beaucoup de questions pour vous sur
beaucoup de ces sujets là qui soulève un
débat particulier d'ailleurs une
première question est ce que vous
trouvez que le débat autour des
questions de la laïcité de séparatisme
est trop crispés en france dépassionner
ce débat alors ce débat il est passionné
mais vous savez en france on a une
spécificité qui est unique au monde
puisque nous sommes les seuls à avoir
dans notre constitution la laïcité
pour nous il n'ya pas plus inclusif que
la conception de l'accueil français
c'est notre grandeur c'est notre
spécificité
cette loi de 1905 elle s'est fait contre
les catholiques avec une énorme
agressivité qu'on a totalement oublié
aujourd'hui mais quand on relit les
débats à l'assemblée nationale et au
sénat c'était un anticlérical féroce
c'est une spoliation aussi des biens de
l'église
il ya eu des personnes qui ont été
bannis notamment des religieux donc ça a
été d'une extrême violence
aujourd'hui nous sommes le pays
malheureusement qui a su du pays
d'europe qui a subi le plus le plus
violemment d' attaque terroriste
nous sommes celui qui a payé le plus
lourd tribut en termes d'attentes à nous
sommes aussi le pays qui paye le plus
lourd tribut en termes d'opérations
extérieures puisque la france lutte au
mali contre le terrorisme et qui a plus
de 50 soldats qui sont morts
j'ai donc ces questions de de lutte
contre le terrorisme islamique
elles sont extrêmement importante mais
ce que je voudrais dire surtout c'est
que notre modèle ce n'est pas le
communautarisme notre colère notre
modèle c'est l'universalisme et que cet
universalisme
moi j'y tiens énormément c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement précieux et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il était important
que dans ce texte le séparatisme on vote
on vote des amendements qui nous
permettent de lutter contre des dérives
comme par exemple syndicat unef
j'ai une question là tu as des heures
oui j'ai une question d'attitude de la
part des remèdes qui dit vous appelé à
la dissolution de l'unef en raison des
réunions non mixtes pourquoi ne pas
faire de même avec le très sélect
automobile club qui est interdit aux
femmes
non mais d'abord on traite pas comparer
ce genre de choses à une action qu'ils
le fassent mais c'était d'aider des
réunions non mixtes à racialiser c'est
un club c'est un syndicat à syndicats et
surtout diversité ainsi qu'à un syndicat
un syndicat étudiant en tout cas c'est
pas interdit aux personnes qui n'ont pas
la bonne couleur pour pour ces personnes
ça c'est clair
un syndicat étudiant reçoit des
subventions publiques pour la défense
d'un certain nombre de chances de 600000
euros
peut-être sauvé l'unaf jeu
j'ai pu lui sur ces organisations
représentatives étudiantes
c'est une organisation lancé une fatwa
comme ils l'ont fait à grenoble contre
des professeurs organiser des réunions
non mixtes s'opposer au fait pour pour
certaines de leurs actions ou des
actions qui l'ont soutenu que par
exemple des personnalités qui ne sont
pas de ma famille politique mais que je
respecte parce qu'elle s'opposait à la
gestation pour autrui comme sylviane
agacinski face des conférences etc
c'est quelque chose quand même qui font
partie de dérives qui sont contre
l'esprit de l'université française qui
est là pour est ouvert à tout le monde
et discuter de tous en toute
circonstance et aujourd'hui franchement
le message en tout cas moi qui me tient
profondément à coeur c'est celui de
l'universalisme républicain dans lequel
nous évoluons qu'est-ce que vous restez
là qu'est ce que vous répondu et par
exemple la mélanine us la présidente de
l'unef qui vous rétorquerez que ces
réunions mixtes sont des groupes de
paroles pour personnes qui subissent des
discriminations
de la même manière que le mlf réunissait
des femmes entre femmes qu'elles
arrêtent de nous prendre pour des
imbéciles
avec ce type de réflexion parce que moi
j'aimerais bien savoir ce qu'elle
pourrait dire de réunions qui sont
interdites à certaines personnes en
fonction de la couleur de leur peau et
c'est un moment donné vous répondrai que
c'est pas la merci de vous intéresser
contre les musulmans vous voyez ce que
je veux dire oui mais c'est trop facile
de toute façon
là la justice tranchera et on verra bien
ce qu'elle tire on verra bien j'ai aussi
une question de totti qui vous demandent
à ce que j'ai saisie avait causé la
france effectivement la justice voir ce
qu'il en est et on verra ce que la
justice dira totti vous demande pourquoi
madame boyer et elle contre les signes
ostentatoires d'appartenance à une
religion lorsque l'on parle du voile
alors qu'elle porte elle même une croix
autour du cou alors ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui à vous laver j'enlève jamais
dans le cadre du tourisme représentante
vous êtes vous êtes élu de la république
et vont porter un signe d'abandon votre
appartenance religieuse d'abord cru pour
vous c'est une atteinte à la laïcité ou
par pas du tout d'abord ça fait partie
de ma liberté d'abord je ne suis pas
astreintes à un devoir de neutralité en
tant qu'élu c'est la première chose
ensuite c'est pas un signe ostentatoire
parce que je les mesures est tellement
j'ai été attaqué sur cette croix elle
mesure 1 cm donc c'est pas un signe
ostentatoire
deuxièmement je le répète la croix n'est
pas un symbole d'oppression de même que
portait une manne fatma ou un méga salle
du choisi de la cetera
ce n'est pas un symbole d'oppression le
problème du voile c'est pas un signe
religieux
moi ce qui me gêne c'est c'est le signe
du manque d'altérité que ça signifie et
je ne peux pas imaginer qu'on puisse
séparer en france le monde entre les
pudiques et les impudiques voilà ce que
ça signifie je ne peux pas imaginer non
plus qu'un homme ne puisse pas retenir
ses pulsions parce qu'ils voient une
mèche de cheveux qui s'échappe
de fin qui est sûr sur la tête d'une
femme et je pense à toutes ces femmes
qui sont martyrisés aujourd'hui qui sont
allés en prison je vous savez j'avais
j'ai cité jeu chad roth d'yvan donc je
prononce mal le nom cette iranienne qui
est devenue française
aujourd'hui qui disait combien s'était
enfermé les femmes dans leur sexe que de
porter le voile cette femme est allée en
prison parce qu'elle refusait de porter
le voile
et moi je pense à toutes ces femmes qui
risquent leur vie pour sentir le vent
dans leurs cheveux
donc quand me dise la libérer c'est ce
que vous revendiquez de portes et vous
même une croix vous la dénier à des
funky jeunes le choix de santé ce ne
sont pas des signes comparables lacroix
n'est pas un symbole d'oppression le
voile est un symbole d'oppression de
différenciation entre les hommes et les
femmes certaines son niveau record avec
100 ben oui peut-être mais en france
c'est peut-être que ça sonne qu'on se
sépare pas le monde entre les fit bien
et les autres voilà et c'est ça qui
compte et c'est en france on est pour
l'altérité en france on est pour
l'inclusion en france on est pour
accueillir son semblable
on ne résume pas les gens à leur
communauté il ya un texte qui va arriver
en discussion chez vos collègues députés
demain mais qui arrivera peut-être plus
tard au sénat encore que c'est pas sûr
c'est sur la fin de vie
il trouve que vos collègues les
républicains ont fait le choix de
l'obstruction parlementaire en déposant
plusieurs milliers d'âmes aurier sartre
un collègue louis gay comment est ce que
vous voyez cette initiative de la part
de vos collègues
alors d'abord c'est une question de
karim la larme des républiques larmes
des députés comme des sénateurs
c'est l'amendement c'est à la fois leur
droit mais c'est aussi leur travail et
leurs devoirs quand vous avez ça pour
vous exprimez vous
vous l'exprimer ensuite ce texte vient à
un moment où je trouve ce moment
particulièrement troublant puisqu'on en
est à essayer de sauver des vies et on
en est aussi essayer de faire en sorte
que la souffrance des français qui n'ont
pas pu tenir la main de ceux qui sont
morts de ce qui allait mourir de ceux
qui sont partis de ceux qui sont malades
qui isolé bien sûr ça à ras bord qui ont
une fin de vie isolé seul du fait de la
pandémie est quand même une cicatrice
qui restera très vive je crois dans
l'histoire de cette pandémie en tout cas
dans l'histoire individuelle de chaque
famille moi je pense beaucoup à elle
aujourd'hui nous avons un texte qui
celui qui est la loi
claisse leonetti que les énormément
soutenu ce texte me semble un bon point
d'équilibré
alors certes il manque des départements
il y en a une trentaine aujourd'hui où
il n'y a pas de service de soins
palliatifs et je m'étonne que dans les
160 milliards d'euros qui ont été mis
que la france a emprunté donc pour pour
gérer cette pandémie
il n'y ait pas eu de budget pour ces
soins palliatifs parce que c'est ça la
dignité la dignité c'est accompagner les
gens vous savez si vous faites un
sondage en disant aux personnes est ce
que vous voulez souffrir jusqu'à la fin
de vos jours et tout le monde vous dira
non
en revanche si vous leur dites on vous
prend en charge
on accompagne votre douleur et vous vous
mourrez dignement entouré soigner et
choyés je pense que tout le monde aura
envie et la loi claisse leonetti c'est
ce qu'elle dit aujourd'hui donc moi je
suis pour qu'on applique cette loi
claisse leonetti que les parlementaires
contrôle puisque c'est leur droit et
leur devoir
l'application de ce texte et qu'on mette
des moyens pour les unités de soins
palliatifs
voilà et au jour voyez pourquoi faire le
choix de l'obstruction parlementaire
parce que vos positions vous auriez pu
les défend dans le cadre d'un débat
parlementaire
quand la france est soumise à de
l'obstruction sur la réforme des
retraites si les républicains avaient
des mots très durs contre l'obstruction
pouy mais écoutez c'est une façon de
s'exprimer
pourquoi faire le choix vous pensez que
c'est digne aujourd'hui en pleine
pandémie alors que notre difficulté ça a
été d'accompagner les personnes en fin
de vie ça a été comme une difficulté
majeure de cette pandémie
ce texte arrive au bon moment est ce que
vous pensez de cette ambition qui arrive
après les langues régionales qu'on va
traiter de ce problème de société
alors comment s'est passée qu'on n'a
même pas fait le bilan de la loi clessé
odetti moi je demande déjà le bilan de
la loi léonetti l'application de la loi
léonetti sur ce sujet et surtout qu'on
regarde comment ça se passe aujourd'hui
dans les endroits on nous avons mis des
équipes de soins palliatifs
comment les gens sont pris en charge
parce que si ce texte est mal appliqué
il faut absolument faire en sorte qu'il
le soit parce que c'est indigne
aujourd'hui la dignité c'est d'être
accompagné c'est d'avoir le choix
le texte de loi actuel le permet
maintenant s'il est pas mis en oeuvre
c'est une autre affaire et cette
affaire-là elle doit être réglée
est ce que vous attendez de la part du
gouvernement qu'il décide éventuellement
d'inscrire lui-même une proposition un
projet de loi sur ce sujet
on ne pas se cacher dans une proposition
de loi non non on se cache pas derrière
une proposition de loi on l'appliqué moi
j'attends de la part du gouvernement
qu'il mette en oeuvre ce texte de loi et
que le parlement vérifie et contrôler la
mise en oeuvre de ce texte de loi s'il
ya des améliorations à apporter il
faudra le faire après sa mise en oeuvre
et je rappelle aussi que emmanuel macron
n'avait pas dit grand chose pendant sa
campagne électorale
mais il avait quand même dit que sur les
lois de bioéthique pour qu'elle puisse
avancer il fallait qu'il ya un consensus
or aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de consensus
il ya un coup politique à un moment
c'est que je serai honnête si je vois là
exactement
aujourd'hui il ya un consensus il faut
un consensus sur cette question qui est
fondamentale et j'irai qui est apparu
avec encore plus de douleur pendant
cette pandémie puisqu'on a vu qu une des
difficultés majeures justement que nous
rencontrions c'était l'accompagnement
c'était à la fois sauver des vies mais
c'était l'accompagnement des personnes
en fin de vie
donc je ne pense pas que la le texte qui
est présenté aujourd'hui par le parti
liberté et territoires y répondent
est ce que le clivage une question de
rythme à rocky vous demandez ce que le
clivage autour de la question de la fin
de vie est encore un clivage droite
gauche ou est-ce que ça ne pose pas
plutôt croyants et non croyants
quelle est la place de je dirais ni l'un
ni l'autre
je pense que c'est une
c'est des questions sur lesquelles j'ai
beaucoup travaillé je pense que c'est
une question qui touche à l'intimé qui
touche aussi énormément à l'organisation
des soins et c'est parce que aujourd'hui
il faut vraiment bien connaître
l'hôpital avoir été confronté à ce type
de difficultés et je sais que parmi les
parlementaires qui ont déposé tous ses
amendements les républicains il y en a
qui ont vécu avec leurs parents ce genre
de difficulté et c'est la raison pour
laquelle ils tiennent absolument à faire
en sorte que la dignité humaine soit
préservé jusqu'au bout je ne crois pas
que choisir de mourir de cette façon le
suicide assisté
ça il ya eu une très belle tribune de
michel houellebecq dans le figaro lundi
je crois et un article excellent parce
qu'il est excellent toujours d'une
personne pour qui j'ai beaucoup
d'affection c'est jean leonetti
franchement moi j'ai beaucoup bossé avec
jean léonetti sur ces questions de
bioéthique et notamment au début on
avait eu des petites difficultés parce
que je voulais imposer la vitrification
rapide des ovocytes pour les femmes
enfin pour faire en sorte qu'elles
puissent conserver leur patrimoine
génétique pas être confronté à certaines
difficultés avec les congélation
d'embryons et sur ces questions de fin
de vie aussi j'ai beaucoup travaillé
avec jean leonetti je peux vous assurer
que c'est un problème aussi
d'organisation des soins et c'est sur
l'organisation des soins qu'on doit
travailler absolument et avant de
changer la loi il faut faire un bilan de
son application
est-ce que c'est pas est ce que est ce
que le disposer de sa fin de vie c'est
pas aussi disposer de son propre corps
cinquante ans après la loi veil
voyez où je veux en venir c'est
complètement mais bon vous voyez sang
dispose de son propre corps de faire en
sorte que ce soit la société qui vous
accompagne pour ça c'est difficile
demandez à ces enfants de le faire c'est
compliqué demandé à des professionnels
de santé de le faire alors que
ils ont ils s'engagent avec le serment
d'hippocrate à ne pas le faire c'est
aussi très difficile donc aujourd'hui
contrairement à ce que prétend de ceux
qui ont déposé ce texte nous avons des
éléments
je suis désolée de me répéter mais
signalaient pas le texte de jean
leonetti je vous le dirai pourquoi pas
travailler là dessus mais c'est pas le
cas donc c'est un faux je pense que
c'est un faux combat et c'est un combat
qui n'est pas opportun dans l'état
actuel des choses il y à 50 ans l'ops le
nouvel observateur publié le manifeste
des 343 343 femmes qui revendiquent
avoir pratiqué une ivg
à l'occasion de ses 50 ans 343 autres
femmes revendiquent elles réclament
l'extension du délai de l'hiver est ce
que vous êtes favorable a priori non je
pense que le délai est suffisant tout
cas c'est ce que disent les sociétés
médicales aujourd'hui
là encore c'est encore un problème
d'organisation des soins vous savez
c'est quelque chose qui est sans fin il
ya déjà eu une extension alors
maintenant que les que l'hôpital soit
mal organisés qu'ils aient des
difficultés des délais d'attenté etc
c'est une chose moi je pense qu'il
faudrait renforcer l'accompagnement des
femmes qui ont recours à une ivg plus
qu'il ne l'est aujourd'hui et leur
permettent d'apporter plus tard ne fait
pas partie de cette amélioration de
l'accompagnement je pense que il faut
travailler avec les femmes qui
malheureusement ont recours plusieurs
fois l ivg puisque vous savez que c'est
le cas se poser la question pour de
savoir pourquoi le chiffre est aussi
important aujourd'hui parce que ça ce
sont des vraies questions de santé
publique qui sont rarement évoquée mais
remettre sans arrêt cette question sans
avoir fait ce travail préalable me
semble pas une bonne chose
vous savez on avait fait la différence
entre le foetus l'embryon rallonger
encore le délai
à mon avis il ya d'autres choses à faire
avant d'accord vos collègues députés
sont en train d'examiner la loi climat
elle arrivera au sénat bientôt jouer ça
vous fait sourire vos collègues les
républicains l'assemblée nationale
fustige une loi qui porte en elle de
l'écologie punitive
j'ai vu des questions d'internautes qui
voulait savoir que c'est quoi pour vous
l'écologie punitive
d'abord je voudrais dire que c'est sous
la droite que le climat a pris une
importance que
importante a une importance vraiment
parler du grotesque
je parle je parle du fait qu'aujourd'hui
nous avons un texte qui a valeur
constitutionnelle qui consacre jacques
chirac qu'il a été qu'il a été voté et
mis en place donc le changement de la
constitution alors qu'on a un texte à
valeur constitutionnelle me semble
totalement favorable en référeront sur
l'article 20 de la constitution
moi je suis fait je suis favorable au
référendum pour un problème politique je
suis sûr qu emmanuel macron le perdra
donc qu'il y aille
mais enfin on était en effet non mais
vous verrez qu il le perdra mais on
n'est pas capable de on n'est pas
capable aujourd'hui d'organiser les
élections d'ailleurs j'aimerais bien
savoir comment il compte organiser le
référendum c'est une petite paroisse
notation sur l'allongement question que
je pose j'espère que j'aurai la réponse
sur la loi climat l'écologie punitive
déjà c'est l'entrée en politique
effective les écologistes qui me semble
quand même assez dramatique entre la
suppression et sapins de noël
elle dé du tour de france maintenant
avoir des remarques sur les rêves des
enfants comme la maire de poitiers qui
s'est fait connaître à cette occasion ça
me semble d'une tristesse qui ne plaide
pas en faveur en faveur des écologistes
je crois que tout le monde a à coeur de
défendre sont le climat l'environnement
etc
ça c'est extrêmement important notamment
les jeunes nota belle et jeune je sais
c'est ce même en faire un bisou
génération ne connaît pas mal juste que
les jeunes parmi ceux qui avec
l'écologie évidemment ils sont très
nombreux à parler d'écologie mais je
rappelle qu'il n'était peut-être pas nés
quand jacques chirac a voté un texte a
fait voter un texte à valeur
constitutionnelle donc je me permets de
le rappeler pour répondre à ce texte a
pas l'air de très bien marché ce moment
ils vont répondre est que ce texte a pas
l'air de suspense a quand même l'air de
bien marcher en france puisque je crois
que nous faisons partie des pays les
plus vert du monde en terme de
demont de gaz
de gaz à effet de serre puisqu'on est à
0,9 pour cent si mais si ma mémoire est
bonne puisque les chiffres ont été
publiés cette année et que ça quand même
c'est un effort considérable mais ce que
je reproche à ce texte elle qui nous
l'avons vu à l'assemblée nationale c'est
à la fois d'enfoncer des portes ouvertes
des choses qui existent déjà comme par
exemple les menus végétariens à la
cantine mais ça fait quinze ans que ça
existe enfin un moment donné il faut
arrêter de prendre les français pour des
idiots
c'est aussi de ne pas j'allais dire de
ne pas assez travailler sur la
préservation de notre patrimoine et
notamment je pense à nos paysages
quand aujourd'hui vous avez ce forcing
pour les nouveaux liens avec les
éoliennes d'éoliennes avec
avec le l'assèchement des sols avec ces
plots monstrueux en béton et le fait
qu'on ne sait pas comment faire
jusqu'à présent pour recycler les pales
aussi qui sont faites avec des métaux
qui sont extrêmement polluants etc
ça me semble quelque chose d'important à
traiter quand on signe des traités pour
notre agriculture avec des pays aussi
aussi éloignés que le brésil le canada
et cetera pour avoir des produits
agricoles qu'on peut très bien faire en
france à en respectant toutes les normes
que nous nous imposons que nous nous
imposons et qui sont extrêmement
positives à la fois pour la qualité de
nos aliments mais aussi pour pour pour
la pollution
ça ça me semble être en contradiction
totale avec les objectifs que l'on peut
poursuivre est-ce que excusez moi oui
ils ont raison c'est une question qui
avait été posé sur le chat je l' ai vu
passer est ce que vous pensez qu'il est
possible d'avoir une croissance verte
est ce que la croissance économique est
compatible avec la préservation de
l'environnement
je le pense je le crois vraiment mais il
faut pas non plus se tromper de combat
et il faut pas faire ça de façon
totalement isolé je vais vous prendre
l'exemple du bio oui bien évidemment
j'ai la chance de faire partie de ces
personnes qui peuvent choisir ce qu'elle
mange
et comment elles mangent mais ça fait
très longtemps parce que j'ai su foulée
j'ai été un petit peu élevé comme ça
j'avais une maman que j'ai
malheureusement plus mais qui était très
attentive à ce genre de choses et
notamment aux frais légumes de saison au
circuit court et c'est même pour ça elle
ici je faisais attention et donc on a
été un petit peu élevé dans ce climat ce
qui est une bonne chose en ayant
conscience de de notre environnement et
de la qualité de la préservation de cet
environnement
mais aujourd'hui quand vous voyez sur
nos étals des produits bio qui viennent
de très loin dont on sait parfaitement
qu'il ne respecte pas les mêmes normes
que nous alors que vous avez des
agriculteurs que l'on a somme de normes
qui en france sont respectées et on voit
bien qu'on organise une concurrence
déloyale qui nous est défavorable
et c'est pour ça aussi qu'il y a entre
j'allais dire les ayatollahs du verre et
ceux qui essayent de défendre une
certaine forme de consommation locale
raisonnée parfois un choc
donc moi je suis convaincu qu'on peut
avoir une croissance verte dans la
mesure où on arrive à être respecté par
les pays qui nous environne par exemple
quand on consomme des produits chinois
mais c'est une question je vous pose de
pas qui ne respectent pas les normes
sociales environnementales humaine dire
clairement en faisant travailler des
prisonniers politiques parce qu'on parle
beaucoup des ouigours aujourd'hui mais
malheureusement il n'y a pas que il ya
les tibétains il ya des chrétiens
il ya le fal en dông il ya toutes ces
minorités qui aujourd'hui sont sont
torturés quand vous êtes favorable à une
taxe carbone aux frontières de l'union
européenne
je suis favorable à ce que excusez moi
d'employer cette métaphore à ce qu on
boxe armes égales
on ne peut pas d'un côté nous nous
imposer des normes et faire en sorte
qu'on fasse venir en france des produits
qui ne respectent pas ces normes
voilà c'est tout tout simplement mais on
peut pas d'un côté dire avec le
gouvernement on va voter la loi climat
est signée le ceta le mercosur et autres
et autres accords qui défavorise notre
agriculture on arrive on se lâche et
manifester avec les agriculteurs quand
c'était à l'assemblée nationale on
arrive bientôt à la fin de cette
émission de sept heures d'échangés une
dernière question on est là sur une
plateforme sur internet dans le chat il
ya beaucoup de pseudo
vous avez porté une proposition sur sur
la carte d'identité numérique
vous êtes contre le pseudonymat sur
internet non parce que je pense qu'il ya
des personnes qui ne peuvent pas
communiquer avec leur nom et
pour plein de raisons professionnelles
que je sais je suis en revanche je suis
pour qu'on puisse les retrouver et je
suis pour aussi qu'on puisse jamais les
insultes si jamais un tel enjeu sans
peau etc
vous savez moi j'ai été victime je suis
toujours de propos haineux etc
quand j'ai déposé plainte de menaces de
mort etc
quand j'ai des pots de vin dans your man
on peut passer à l'étranger donc c'est
ça qui est pas possible
un moment donné il faut à la fois taxer
toutes ces entreprises pour ce cas pas
de région du numéro i jah les géants du
numérique et deuxièmement qu'on puisse
retrouver ces personnes c'est la raison
pour laquelle je soutiendrai tout à
l'heure où demain un amendement qui va
dans ce sens là dans la loi séparatisme
et je sais que là vous devez retourner
dans l'hémicycle pour aller défendre les
amendements merci valérie boyer d'avoir
accepté mon invitation merci à vous
d'avoir regardé cette émission merci à
très bientôt sur public sénat ciao